والحديث عن الزلازل لا يزال مستمرا تنبؤات
وتضارب في النظريات اخرها تحذير من العالم
التركي ناجيجورو احد اشهر خبراء الزلازل
في تركيا وفي حديث خاص مع العربيه نت حذر
العالم من فجوه مرعبه وزلزال بقوه عشر
درجات على مقياس ريختر ستضرب اسطنبول ودون
تحديد توقيت لذلك الوقت السبب يعود بحسب
الخبير كما قال العربينت لوجود فجوه
زلزاليه في اسطنبول وعندما يتم سد هذه
الفجوه سيحدث زلزال مرمره الكبير والمدمر
رافضا التعليق على توقعات العالم الهولندي
فرانكو بعدما توقع زلزال مدمرا بتركيا في
الثامن من مارس الزلزال القاسي سيكون
بمثابه زلزلين متتاليين لكن يمكن
اعتبارهما اربعه زلازل في وقت واحد لشده
قوته حيث دعا رئيس بلديه المدينه الى
الاستعانه بالعلم لتقسيط سعانه بالعالم
لتقليص حجم الخسائر في حال وقوعه اسط نبول
التي تضم 16 مليون شخص
سيتاثر الجانب الاسيوي منها بنسبه اقل من
الجانب الاوروبي بحسب العالم غورو كما قال
العرب يرد